bella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo blog e io sono fa vj oggi
ho parecchie cose da dirvi allora ho
iniziato malissimo non ho tante cose da
dirvi ma diciamo che è quel poco che vi
devo dire è abbastanza lungo quindi
cerco di velocizzare i tempi allora come
al solito inizio blog facendo vedere una
fan art
la frase di oggi è stata fatta da dei
dari a14 è veramente fantastica mio
parere ci sono io in una posizione
fantastica e dietro invece è ovviamente
lo slider che decora tutto quanto poi in
basso a sinistra c'è il cagnolino che
secondo me è fantastico ed è fantastico
ovviamente anche alla mia alla mia
sinistra il il mostro di amnesia ecco
poi tra l'altro io un'espressione tipo
roba del genere non so comunque va beh è
veramente fantastica ti ringrazio dei
d'aria severamente una grandissima
artista le due fan arte che mi hai fatto
fino adesso sono veramente fantastiche
vi ricordo che se volete provare a farne
una voglia anche disegnato a mano al
compito come preferite
basta che mettete mi piace alla pagina
di facebook in descrizione mela scrivete
c'è ma la mela inviate sua pagina di
facebook
comunque cerco di velocizzare i tempi
perché veramente tosti fare uno spiegone
assurdo come avete letto del titolo e
stavolta non faccio il file al trota ho
fatto così ma il titolo in realtà è
sotto perché youtube ogni tot di mesi si
fuma qualche canna decide di cambiare un
po il design quindi come avete detto nel
titolo
parteciperò al youm kubert 2013 e sono
ovviamente felicissimo di questa di
questa cosa
molti di voi lo sapevano già perché
avevamo visto il video io non ho potuto
dirvi niente ma adesso vi spiego tutto
dall'inizio anche perché c'è chi tra voi
non conosce appunto non sa che cosa in
youtubers allora ogni anno ogni anno non
so verso che periodo comunque dipende
ogni anno viene organizzato questo
torneo
questo è il terzo dai ragazzi vi
parliamo di videogiochi questo torneo
consiste nel
nella sfida tra vari youtubers
conosciuti quest'anno sono stato
invitato anch'io l'anno scorso mi pare
che hanno partecipato fare nce e albi
insieme ad altri youtubers che adesso
non mi ricordo comunque per farvi capire
più meno il livello delle youtubers che
partecipano al via fares sono
conosciutissimi quest'anno sono stato
invitato anche io non ci potevo credere
quando avevo visto e non ho potuto
parlarvene perché mi è stato proibito di
di parlarvene perché ovviamente
youtubers è una delle serie più seguite
in tutta italia di di youtube in
generale per quanto riguarda i
videogiochi e diciamo i ragazzi vi
parliamo di videogiochi vogliono sempre
tenere tutto segreto fino a pochi giorni
prima dell'uscita della serie quindi io
lo sapevo circa già da un mese ma non ho
potuto dirvelo in principio l'invito mi
è stato mandato sul canale di share e
gaming ma purtroppo a questa a questa
edizione di job cuber si può partecipare
soltanto può partecipare soltanto uno
youtubers per canale
e adesso vi spiegherò perché
innanzitutto vi dico che la sfida di
quest'anno prevede sette youtubers che
sono tanti rispetto agli anni scorsi e
più 7 utenti normali di youtube che sono
stati scelti a random già scelti che
avranno la possibilità che italiano ci
avranno la possibilità di sfidare noi
noi youtubers il videogame in questione
è minecraft la sfida verrà fatta su
minecraft e consiste negli hunger games
che equa ragazzi appena l'ho saputo
veramente ho lanciato un urlo tipo
qualche [ __ ] sì adesso vi spiego
subito perché hunger games è una saga
che prevede ci sono tre romanzi che poi
stanno facendo i film sono recenti per
di mente il primo è uscito soltanto il
primo dei tre romanzi di film ed è
uscito un anno fa praticamente gli
hunger games sono della faccio proprio
breve
14 data sono 24 comunque 14 persone
perché su youtubers siamo in 14 vengono
scelte emesse in un'arena a scannarsi
finché non ne rimane uno vivo quello
vivo vince è questo scontro viene
seguito in diretta da milioni e milioni
di persone per quanto riguarda il film
appunto
e qui è più o meno la stessa cosa solo
che non siamo noi a scannarci nella vita
reale cioè non è che io adesso vado in
giro con le pistole a vado ad ammazzare
gli altri ma ovviamente l'affare fosse
un minecraft e ci seguirete in live e
poi verrà ritrasmesso anche sul canale
di parliamo di videogiochi per chi non
l'ha seguito live e non solo elencarvi
youtubers in questione che
parteciperanno quest'anno perché anche
perché non me li ricordo tutti comunque
visto a dire che tutti youtubers imitati
tutti giocano a minecraft e fanno video
soltanto su minecraft io sono l'unico
che è stato invitato che non fa video su
minecraft quindi parto svantaggiati simo
perché ovviamente loro facendo mai
capito tutti i giorni lo conoscono
benissimo io sì ho mai che ho giocato ci
ho giocato ci giocavo un anno fa
abbastanza però
non è da un anno che praticamente quasi
non lo tocco e e vabbè quindi sarà
abbastanza difficile comunque appena
avevo finito di appena finito di vedere
il film hunger games me ne innamorai
talmente tanto che provai a cercare su
su internet c'era qualche videogame
uscito di hunger games appunto è l'unico
che trovai e minecraft la moda di
minecraft di hunger games che è quella
che andrò a fare per new tuber però
ragazzi non giocandoci mai quindi non da
secoli che non ci gioco e non giocando a
minecraft la vedo un po difficile ma
l'importante che è che ci divertiamo
comunque veramente quando ho finito di
vedere il film mi dovrò prendere anche i
romanzi perché sono fantastici comunque
una volta finito di vedere film hunger
games
la prima cosa che mi è venuta mente dire
mica mi piacerebbe un casino partecipare
una cosa del genere è veramente caso
vuole sono stato invitato a youtubers e
caso vuole ancora non so com'è possibile
il gioco in questione proprio hunger
games ed è seguito praticamente in tutta
italia quindi veramente
sono onorato di essere tra i sette
youtubers scelti vi dirò io comunque
quando ci sarà il live e nel caso
comunque se non riuscite a vederlo vi
linkerò poi magari in un blog futuro
il video di dove è stato pubblicato per
chi non ha visto live
vi dico subito che comunque il live sarà
mi pare sarà il primo febbraio mi pare
alle 5 poi non so se ci sono cambiamenti
di orario alle 5 ovviamente di
pomeriggio e niente di farlo sapere
prima quando sto per iniziare è comunque
nel caso poi vi farò vedere video più
avanti per chi non l'ha visto veramente
voglio ringraziare i ragazzi di parliamo
di videogiochi per avermi dato questa
possibilità è niente passiamo oltre poi
vi farò sapere vi ringrazio per per
tutti i complimenti che mi avete fatto
perché mi incoraggiate nel vincere
questa sfida
non so se riuscirà a vincere ma va beh
l'importante che mi diverta che vi
divertiate voi che ci divertiamo tutti
quanti proseguiamo perché ho altre cose
da dirvi ciò la scaletta qui me la sono
preparata ragazzi allora new beurs ok
allora molti di voi mi hanno chiesto per
la coop con dildo la coop condivido l'ho
registrata l'abbiamo registrato insieme
circa tre giorni oggi domenica 15 tre
giorni fa l'abbiamo fatta su sei in
trovo come vi avevo già detto e non vi
voglio dire niente appunto perché non mi
voglio spiegare nulla però volevo
veramente ringraziare dio perché
è una persona veramente fantastica c'è
noi vabbè ci conoscevamo già ci siamo
già sentiti e il bello che quando quando
ci siamo connessi su skype per poter
registrare i tre episodi era bellissimo
perché io tipo dalle l'abbiamo
registrato alle nuove io dalle 8 ho
cominciato a guardare l'ora tipo così
perché e roero tesissimo è veramente non
non vedevo l'ora di iniziare però
veramente ero tesissimo perché c'è io
veramente di dolore avuto un grandissimo
youtuber che io stesso seguo quindi ero
veramente tesissimo ragazzi e quando ci
siamo chiamati su skype anche lui mi ha
scritto che era veramente teso è
veramente ragazzi sono stato c'è
veramente mi sono commosso del fatto che
anche vito era diciamo era in ansia che
stava per fare un commento di con me
diciamo che eravamo tesi a vicenda di
fare commentari l'uno con l'altro ecco
diciamo ci siamo divertiti veramente
tantissimo
ve lo dico ragazzi sarà una coop
straordinaria questo velo preannuncia è
fantastica
sono il primo episodio forse non so
perché ma vabbè l'abbiamo passato a metà
episodio che abbiamo passato a creare il
personaggio quindi comunque è stato
veramente fantastico non sto dicendo che
è noioso assolutamente non c'è da noi
arsi con questa coop ve lo posso
assicurare e lo vedrete avrete la
conferma ma secondo me da secondo
episodio in poi sono un qualcosa di
fantastico ragazzi
premetto che ci sarà il primo episodio
sui canali di di dopo il secondo sarò
sul mio il terzo sarò su quello di vibo
è il quarto primo sul mio andremo avanti
così uno a testa comunque veramente è
stato fantastico voglio ringraziare
un'altra volta di do per aver fatto per
aver scelto di fare questa coop con me è
veramente ragazzi poi ci saranno altri
progetti adesso vedremo stiamo
organizzando io di.do.re csen era una
coop che adesso non sapremo se ce la
faremo diciamo è un po è una cosa un po
preannunciata diciamo se un po vedendo
come possiamo organizzarci per questa
cosa però io rex in d2 runner stiamo per
fare una coop in 4 su non so se posso
dirvelo ragazzi perché detto non l'ha
specificato quindi non mi sento di
specificarlo neanche io ho visto che è
una cosa che organizzato lui vi dico
solo che parteciperò sicuramente perché
è veramente sarebbe una cosa fantastica
io di durex nera nel non so che cosa può
uscire comunque vi dico solo che il
videogame in questione di questa coop in
quattro e veramente strepitoso che avrei
fatto comunque in qualche modo comunque
l'avrei fatto prima o poi e sono
contento di farlo e in questa coppa
veramente fantastico comunque ragazzi
proseguiamo allora un altro punto
importante è razzle nello scorso blog ho
detto ragazzi se c'è qualcuno che mi
vuole aggiungere il suo razzle che è
un'applicazione per iphone e android
sono fa vj hem i pomi può aggiungere su
razzle e possiamo fare una partita
questa cosa non vale più per il semplice
fatto che io nello scorso blog l'ho
semplicemente accennato due minuti dopo
che ho pubblicato il blog mi sono
arrivate tipo 100 richieste di
partecipazione alle partite di 100
richieste di sfida su razzle c'è ragazzi
siete pazzi
cioè non posso partecipi gli avevo detto
ragazzi io gioco a razzo nei tempi morti
quindi magari cinque minuti al giorno ma
neanche c'è dipende a volte non ci gioco
proprio a volte ci giocano i miei
compagni quando si impossessano nel mio
telefono
e quindi ragazzi mi avete mandato tante
di quelle richieste che veramente non
posso giocare con tutti
avrò fatto sì e no una decina di partite
dallo scorso blog della scorsa settimana
e se accetto se ho accettato le vostre
partite e non ho giocato non è perché mi
state sul culo state tranquilli ma
semplicemente perché siete veramente in
tantissimi ed è impossibile accontentare
tutti
e veramente csv accetto le partite e non
le star topoi è semplicemente per il
fatto che siete in tanti o semplicemente
se vi vedete la richiesta annullata e
razzle che l'elimina in automatico
perché ci sono delle volte che ricevo
troppe richieste e quindi razzo le
annulla in automatico
vi giuro ragazzi il primo giorno con i
giorni a seguire è stato un continuo il
mio cellulare vibrava ogni due secondi
perché mi arrivava una notifica qualcuno
ti ha sfidato suo razzo è stato un
qualcosa di assurdo e dopo tre o quattro
giorni dall uscita del blog dovuto
cancellare razzle dal mio cellulare
perché veramente era un qualcosa di
inconcepibile
quindi ragazzi scusatemi se veramente
non posso fare queste partite sul razzo
e con voi ma siete veramente in tanti
io non avevo idea vi giuro che foste in
così tanti e a sfidarmi anche perché non
pensavo è veramente scusatemi se non ho
giocato con voi per quelli con cui ho
giocato scusate se non ho finito le
partite ma veramente non ho tanto tempo
per poter far partite siete veramente in
infinita quindi ragazzi
limitiamoci a se volete fare una partita
come mi vedete mai su steam a giocare a
qualcosa e potete partecipare
partecipate tranquillamente però su
razzle non c'è basta
volevo fare un ringraziamento speciale
european gaming channel che è un ragazzo
che mi mi aiuta mi consiglia sempre
videogame quindi nuovi meli consigliate
sempre tutti ma lui in particolare mi
consiglia a tutti i videogames nuovi
horror e non che siano in d quindi
ragazzi ti ringrazio innanzitutto per
questo è colgo l'occasione per
ricordarvi che se vedete un videogame
bello che vi sembra che io possa
recensire nuovo possibilmente nuovo
perché sei nuovo c'è molta più
possibilità che lo faccia consigliate
melo mandatemi un messaggio ma non
scrivetelo nei commenti o su facebook
dove vi pare comunque consigliate me la
vedrò se è opportuno farlo anche perché
da solo è un po difficile vedere tutte
le uscite quindi diciamo a volte è una
cosa un po complicata quindi se avete
dei videogame da consigliarmi fatelo al
massimo magari vi dico secondo me non va
bene oppure l'ho già fatto
oppure l'hanno già fatto in tanti
insomma se è nuovo comunque c'è molta
più possibilità
ok ultima cosa prima di passare alle
domande
molti di voi mi hanno chiesto nella
puntata di penombra fa vj ma tu sei
veramente aracnofobia cioè hai paura dei
ragni ragazzi io non scherzavo quando
quando dicevo nei video che io ho paura
dei ragni non ho fatto tutte quelle
scenate per niente io veramente ho
questa fobia dalla nascita
molti di voi pensavano che io
schiacciassi ma io veramente non scherzo
quando quando vedo ste cose
non so se dovuto un trauma infantile non
ne ho la più pallida idea forse una cosa
ereditaria semplicemente però a me fanno
veramente veramente schifo come ad
esempio ad alcuni fanno schifo i
serpenti che invece a me non fanno per
niente schifo anzi a costo di perdere un
braccio la carrozzeria anche un serpente
ma i ragni veramente mi fanno schifo
ragazzi è comunque cosa di ma di anche
di oltre lo schifo cioè io non li
sopporto quindi per quelli che mi hanno
chiesto se avevo veramente questa fobia
sì è vero è l'ultima cosa prima di
passare alle domande anche se da quella
di prima all ultima cosa ho notato
ultimamente che le visualizzazioni del
canale non dei video se si sono sempre
alte sono in crescita io vi ringrazio
veramente sempre perché è una cosa
fantastica ragazzi suono commosso come
esprimermi la mia felicità per per
quello che fate per me per i video che
vedete sempre
e che mi seguite così tanto ragazzi
veramente io vi ringrazio tantissimo ma
sono rimasto sorpreso anche per le
visualizzazioni del canale che ho notato
che al giorno sono più o meno 2000 cioè
significa che 2000 di voi al giorno
guardando il mio canale per vedere se
sono usciti dei video e ho avuto la
conferma perché il giorno in cui non ho
messo un video perché avevo dei problemi
sempre per quanto riguarda la coop con
di indossavo evitando delle cose quindi
non potendolo potuto caricare il video
non ho avuto il tempo di editare video
del giorno dopo
quindi giorno dopo non ho messo il video
ha notato che quel giorno le
visualizzazioni del canale sono salite
alle stelle perché molti di voi
aspettavano il video e quindi
continuavano ad aggiornare il canale è
il video non è uscito per ovvi motivi
perché non potevo comunque ragazzi
veramente solo il nostro sorpreso che il
canale ha avuto veramente così tante
visualizzazioni specialmente anche quel
giorno perché significa che voi
aspettate i miei video che che escano è
veramente sa cosa mi fa veramente
piacere vi giuro
quindi ragazzi grazie grazie per tutto
per tutto per tutto questo in generale e
niente veramente grazie vi ringrazio
ancora di cuore e direi che possiamo
passare i commenti e direi che possiamo
passare alle domande
ok ragazzi la prima domanda arriva da
banks 943 toni genoa la maglietta del
psg non la metti più allora maglietta
del psg ragazzi sarebbe questa la
maglietta si possa aprire un outlet non
a catena di abbigliamento ragazzi
primavera estate fa vj tv comunque la
maglietta non la metto semplicemente per
il fatto che in maniche corte è qui a
torino
in questo periodo si gela dal freddo io
adesso sono in maniche lunghe sto
gelando mentre sto facendo blog
anche se non sembra e quindi veramente
fare un blog o video che sia con questo
addosso è un suicidio
quindi appena tornerò a fare un po di
caldo ovviamente la metterò
bene passiamo direttamente alla seconda
domanda che questa volta mi è stata
fatta da mister ma in crack fa vigesse
faccio una fan art come te la mando
allora ragazzi le fan art e mele potete
mandare sulla pagina di facebook sulla
mia pagina di facebook che trovate come
sempre in descrizione in ogni mio video
volendo anche anche qui su youtube ma su
facebook c'è praticamente il 100 per
cento di possibilità che io lo vedo
perché io su facebook sulla pagina di
facebook e rispondo sempre a tutte le
vostre domande e guardo sempre tutto
quello che tutti i commenti che mi
pubblicata anche se a volte non ho tempo
di rispondere io leggo tutto lì soltanto
che le fan art e non potendole mettere
nel nei commenti potete metterle
semplicemente sulu su facebook sua
pagina di facebook che vi ripeto per la
500 miliardi di una volta la trovate in
ogni video in descrizione no perché
molti me lo scrivono ragazzi che fa vj
come faccio a trovare la tua pagina di
facebook
nonostante lo ripeto sempre c'è sempre
come lo chiede lo trovate in descrizione
così come in ogni videogame che faccio
trovate il download
sì invece per quanto riguarda le domande
del blog se volete farmene alcune queste
dovete scrivere qua sotto nei commenti
del blog in tutti i commenti dei blog io
poi quando faccio il blog successivo
guardi guardi commenti che mi avete
mandato del nel blog precedente ok
ragazzi dovrei avervi detto tutto
scusate se le domande in questo blog
erano poche ma veramente
non ho tantissimo tempo vi ringrazio
come al solito per tutte le
visualizzazioni per tutti i complimenti
che mi fate per tutti mi piace che
mettete è veramente ragazzi continuerò a
far video a l'ultima cosa che volevo
dirvi mi sono accorto che ho fatto
veramente tantissimi horror ultimamente
anche se gli ultimi e mi ha detto che
erano molto carini specialmente si tipo
slider buso eri che tra l'altro deve
uscire finale tra poco uscirà state
tranquilli
mi sono accorto di averne fatti
veramente troppi e dalla prossima
settimana che uscirà anche il la coop
con dido inizierò a fare sì happy with
come come avevo detto e anche ho trovato
ragazzi un videogame indie che secondo
me è il migliore in assoluto uscito fino
adesso non è un horror ragazzi
ovviamente un videogioco molto
particolare non vi voglio svelare nulla
ma è fantastico e oltre a questo deve
uscire anche scribblenauts e non mi
ricordo se deve uscire qualcosa assi su
motori dreams sì lo devo continuare
comunque in poche parole non farò
soltanto video horror perché molti
pensano che questo canale sia soltanto
horror e non è così e semplicemente per
il fatto che ho dovuto accontentare
moltissime vostre richieste tra slann
derwood ieri e tutte le altre richieste
di videogiochi horror che ho fatto era
semplicemente per il fatto che molti di
voi mi chiedevano da secoli e ho dovuto
accontentarmi più o meno tutti adesso
manca soltanto scp e poi dovrei aver
finito con tutte le richieste che non so
quando farò scp con quello però che
avanti e quindi niente vi assicuro che
oltre agli horror sì perché usciranno
sempre horror comunque far uscire video
anche non horror
ok dovrei avervi detto tutto mi pare che
ci sia qualcos'altro come al solito se
vi è piaciuto video lasciato mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook ritrovati
in descrizione se avete una domanda da
farmi
lasciate un commento qui sotto nel blog
è niente se non sei tra i sinti
iscrivetevi ci vediamo un prossimo video
bella ragazzi